now how do we deal with this guy we saw
before one of the ways of addressing the
hole which which case of this function
do you take when you're doing the exit
knowledge a positive sign to take the
negative sign if you kind of end up with
with which we don't want
we saw you could deal with it last time
when you had that semi circle do you
remember and we were saying I look the
whole city circle is positive right so
we should have a portion of this contain
you should end up with a positive value
right so therefore you kind of do with
that by saying all right well therefore
the whole thing should be positive now
you have to be careful because last time
we could do that because this is what we
ended up with do you remember that does
that ring a bell and you're like cool
that thing is all positive my original
thing
it's also all positive so I said cool
that's all I have to deal with and maybe
going up okay this is somewhat more
tricky isn't it because have a look at
this for starters
okay what do you think can we make the
positive argument with this shape yeah
you can can't we
I have no idea what this shape looks
like certainly not a semicircle but
that's gonna be positive this by
definition is going to be positive so
that looks good but then imagine what
would happen if I just took the took the
plus view case okay let's just for the
sake of argument that maybe here if I
just take the positive case this is
going to be 1 over 9 1 sine squared
what will that become I'm just taking
the positive part right which is sick
theta and that say it was really
actually a closet eater up here
and you okay with that all right now
this is a problem for us I'm not happy
with that okay because even though I
made the argument yeah this thing's all
positive cool there's no such easy
argument with this chair it's clear that
this thing must be more positive just
not at all clear that that's more
positive right I can't make such a
simple argument so therefore what I did
before it's not going to cut it for me
okay so I'm going to return back to
something which I'm gonna explain a
slightly different way which is to
introduce a restriction for theta okay
pri restrictions on X okay but I'm not
gonna worry about them for now I just
want to see the face next wins that's
what really matters to me here's the
restriction I'm going to introduce on
Thea I'm gonna say let me don't be sorry
yeah
I'm gonna introduce this restriction
okay now before you guys on today
he just like exactly that legit I'm
going to try and argue but why yes we
can
okay and I'm gonna meet this layout
remember last time when you go ahead and
do all of the integration we ended up in
a closed beta last time you like how am
i different times cos theta you have to
draw a right angle triangle okay
in other words I'm implying this
restriction so if I want this
restriction if this restriction is
likely necessary for me to move forward
I need to know why anymore so let's
think about this if this is the case why
would this be a problem like why
wouldn't we want a restriction why would
a restrict any problematic
remember I said this question has Simo
sorry this this interview has some
restrictions right what kind of
restrictions do you see ex-con equal
zero
yeah okay because I cut I don't want
that to no man it's a zebra do you see
any other restrictions on this this guy
here yeah I'm trying to ask like what
values of x and this work for which
applies the question what bags were
breaking oriented with one namely
economies where are there any other
fusions looks ok apart from zero right
which is a little bit different what we
had yeah
remember this this had mother it's just
much more extreme to remember that where
does this exist it's a semicircle right
from negative 3 to 3 okay so this is
this is poor man because you can
introduce the restriction here right
that means you're only solving part of
the problem aren't you only solving this
part if this has like very few
restrictions and then you suddenly
introduce one then you're not really
solving the original problem you like
solving a sort of shrunk down version of
the original problem okay
but he's the thing this restriction
actually does not restrict this at all
let me show you how let me try and argue
for you draw for me a really really
small bath it doesn't mean up to 20
hands
or 10x or rather tip you know hey we're
doing and someone can set up different
okay so he's my stupid graph of 10x IV
I've drawn in a very strange domain
you'll see why in a second what I'm
suggesting is that we restrict in here
from there I'm drawing a holy circle
right because I actually don't want that
why do I know what that value because I
actually can't be there anyway right I
can't have X equal to zero so therefore
I don't need feeder to be I'm sorry I
don't have X equal zero so I don't want
any individual zero either so I'm
leaving you now and that's also handy
for me because then I can draw a
triangle through this thing right and
then I'm saying okay what do you keep
going all the way up into you okay now
the first thing I want to point out is
as Junsu said blue Torian negative that
negative values look like they're going
to be a problem yeah because look if you
want that negative value for it is a bit
weird but this is Peter versus X so X in
this case it's actually my variable axis
you notice that there's a bit more okay
but what I want is if I'm if I'm
thinking at how do I get a negative
value of x and you would think I need a
negative value of theta to do it right
like it's supposed I was going to put in
some boundaries like this from here to
here right so you would think oh well X
being negative 1 what value of theta do
you think would be needed for that I
need an actual number right it's gonna
be able he's negative 1 down here
come on you guys know this isn't about
anybody this is negative powerful right
and you're like wait you just you just
took that out of the domain you just
restricted me out of it it does seem
like it's a problem on the face of it
but it's actually not right because look
if this value down to negative 1 right
negative ones never actually going to
appear in my integrand is it because
have a look at the particular kind of
function of God it's all squared do you
notice that these squeeze are going to
come up again and again it's
trigonometric substitutions are involved
because I loved enough in order to use
them you're going to get things squared
so you're using the paper ground and in
all kinds of different versions okay so
it's not just like a fluke then I'm
using a trig substitution here and I've
got squids here which make this really
nice form being that everything is
squared I never actually need to worry
about these values knowing your right if
I want to do right let's let's pick a
different value so let's say I went to
any one college not that interesting
suppose I went down to say negative 2
it's gonna be some weirdo I have no idea
what that value actually is going to be
okay but by the time he enters into this
guy here it's gonna get squared yeah
it's gonna get squared so negative 2 or
square it'll become 4 here and then I'll
become 4 there right so the question
becomes me
can I pick a value of theta that will
give me that value of 4 and the answer
is just I can write all I need can I
pick a value in here all I need is
something when she's on the opposite
side cuz tan is what kind
it's on right so it's like whatever
angle that would have been right
actually can someone do tanning this
video to pointers give me another
we're in radians yeah one point it's
going to be less than between zero and
please one point much yeah now if that's
the value of feet are that would give me
x equals negative two in order to make
it work here it's going to be equivalent
if I say cleaner is positive one point
one which is in this domain right this
is one point five seven ish so it checks
out okay so there are two things that
I'm noticing number one I can actually
leave off the zero okay that's alright
number two I don't need to get to here
because like we just did it for negative
two like a definite you three or four or
five or five hundred because any value
my wire look 10 goes forever
it's range is all real values so no
matter what value makes you what I can
find a value of theta only in this
domain that will give me the result of a
laughter okay like you tell me any X you
like right put in any numbers for one
because this has no restrictions as we
just pointed out
and I can find a theta that would
satisfy for you you might stop getting
really twisted final two because you
might put in you might give you some
large number
okay but that's alright that's the whole
idea in acetone right that you can get
you can get arbitrarily close to it so I
took you out a bit of a twisted turn
right I'm trying to justify this
restrictive if I can justify this then
that we can take care of this absolute
value and I can take just water okay and
also I can do this which I'm going to
need to do tan theater is exon 3x I'll
be able to make this triangle later on
which I'm going to need because I can
justify this restriction here right
you justify that yeah okay it's it is
and honestly I would just draw the
graphic you know obviously don't need to
sit very write a few paragraphs about
why like this this for me is the
justification that any value makes you
want any value x1 I can give you a value
of theater in this domain that will
generate your value of x thanks if you
have to say enough
that's why you need something
not really yeah I know to make this a
complete rigorous proof you would you'd
have to talk through the stuff that I
just talk to you but in reality like now
we're now we're coming down to like exam
we're right like this is an important
part of the proof but it's not the part
of the proof I'm certainly not diverting
three marks in my marketing skills to go
or say yes student has demonstrated yeah
this end is and this and this right
there's not enough yeah we at least just
want you to say hey there's a
restriction that's why this absolute
value I can I can just take one part of
it so I'm looking for you to deal with
that but I'm not looking for like all
the nuts and bolts okay I want you to
know the nuts and bolts so that it's not
just like I don't want to think when it
is you're shooting perform like why are
you because why can we do it because
mystery since I don't know if it is
geometric reasons as too much
No and the reason why is because realize
it why do we encounter this problem
right the reason we encounters problem
is because we use the trig substitution
we introduced that but where a trig
substitution is useful and answer is
they useful in all the cases where
you've got these things happening right
so you're going to get the same pattern
over and over again the sign you've
signed is also like if if I have signed
like this right the restriction was
different it was negative 3 to 3 but
that's ok because 3 sine 3 dot exists
from negative 3 to 3
so any value you want in there you can
find just like I can't hear okay so here
it's like oh no restriction that's okay
you picked 10 right here there's a
restriction but a fiction he exactly
matches the restriction you would get
from this also so it always marries up
like that now I'm aware that was a big
new idea that maybe you're like I'm
still not quite tracking along with that
yet and that's okay this took me a lot
of time in the first
yeah okay but I'll look this here you
can ask me questions about as it settles
into your right a little worn you have a
exhale fun we can progress now okay I am
gonna write this one line
it didn't we don't yeah okay I haven't
requested
I've made this restriction okay and I'm
going to say okay the reason why I'm
taking the positive pot
this
is because as I made the argument over
there I have a domain restriction on
FINA that means that sec theta theta is
always really positive so you absolute I
was enough up he's just to know